ok là choix de la posture stubbs allez
je vais le défoncer là je prends peur
derrière je vais j'y vais on rejoue
demain
donc aucun recul
on sait qu'un autre membre se donnent
quelques temps ce maigre ça donne super
jouer star
je refais toi
rando run cher et beau pays
je vois ici vous êtes infographiste en
freelance depuis trois ans c'est ça oui
c'est exact ce tempo a battu élèves à
leur finish à la bonne heure
english is very good because a été de
bail entre l'egypte et nécessité
advertising intent and some very flou
entre washington et à la haye que team
working aller
ce matin
[Musique]
à
allô oui bonjour c'est un peu pour une
urgence
je crois que je suis coincé d'or le vfm
ma femme et je manquais beurre dans très
peu de temps
oui non non non elle ne s'appelle blague
à l'eau et la macédoine
oui tu pleures pourquoi tu pleures sa
cause de moi 1 c'est parce que je suis
pas l'auteur ce ça du moins telle est la
bonne
et puis pourquoi tu dis ça mais j'ai
trop envie de toi moi mais mais c'est
que je m'en bat a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup envient donc il faut juste
qu'on qu'on trouve langis médiane
tu vas fargo j'aurai du temps par les
[Musique]
icpe ce qui est soutien truc là comme si
tu avais tous ces ampoules que seule
leur fasse
[Musique]
la gauche